Last night was the first of many 2020 democratic
primaries in Iowa.
It is in fact a [inaudible], a
caucus system.
So much anticipation.
Finally, the 2020 democratic primary gets
going.
Finally, we are going to have some information
and data and numbers about it is not just
polls, it is now voting who takes the first
win and unfortunately it is turned into a
world wide embarrassment.
Headlines around the world, embarrassing for
the democratic party as multiple systems apparently
fell apart, results simply stopped being published
after one or 2% of the vote was out.
Almost every aspect of this has been a cartoonish
train wreck and as of this recording, we do
not know who won.
Yesterday we were streaming live yesterday,
a beautiful live stream.
We had a six or 6,000 or so people watching
the entire evening.
Uh, it got to be 9:30 PM Eastern and we had
just a few results.
It got to be 10:00 PM Eastern, 10:30 PM Eastern
and we got a little bit more 11:00 PM nothing.
And eventually just past 11:30 PM Eastern
time on our stream, we realized from looking
at what various DMC officials were putting
out on Twitter that the results were unlikely
to come out last night and that was it for
us for the night and as of this morning we
still do not know who won yesterday's Iowa
caucus.
Now it is normal that it can take a little
while once you have the final vote to get
the final numbers for what are called state
delegate equivalents, but we're talking about
we don't even have the final vote, which is
a preliminary number used to sort of get an
estimate of what the state devil, state, delegate
equivalents are ultimately going to be.
Now the explanations that were being provided
have shifted.
The first explanation was that the results
were delayed because the DNC is running them
through quality control.
That was already probably the wrong lie to
tell if an indeed was a lie because that was
interpreted by Somos.
We don't like the results and thus we are
delaying and seeing what we can do to maybe
change the results or wait for results that
the DNC is happier with to come in so that
they can release them all at once and the
were a lot of people's minds went was this
is meant to hurt Bernie in some way, shape
or form, but it actually doesn't appear to
be the case.
It appears that that was merely a cover.
Again, this is what we believe as of right
now, it appears that the quality control talking
point was a cover for what was the total breakdown
in failure of a technological system and it
internet based app software system that was
used to tally and report the results of the
Iowa caucus.
By the time you hear this, by the time you
watch today's show, you may know the results.
You may have a clearer explanation as to what
exactly happened last night.
The DNC is saying that the results are going
to be released sometime today.
Now in the wake of this, multiple candidates
have claimed to either have internal numbers
showing that they won or gave speeches, making
it sound like they won.
In fact, Amy Klobuchar did something hilarious
last night at around 1115, I think it was
11, 11, 15:00 PM Eastern time.
We had no results.
Amy Klobuchar was in like fourth or fifth
place based on like 2% of the vote at that
time.
She came out and gave a speech that seemed
like a victory speech, even though she hadn't,
she certainly wasn't in the lead and it's
a, she certainly hadn't a, um, we didn't have
enough information to know whether anyone
had one.
She kind of gave a victory speech, which in
a way was genius because nothing was going
on.
Everything was stopped and a whole bunch of
networks ended up covering the globe, a char
speech, even though she was like in fourth
or fifth place with about 10% of the vote
at the time.
Then you had Pete Buddha judge, he, uh, Pete
Buddha judge, which was the early leader yesterday.
He put out a statement kind of like implying
he won.
He says, Iowa, you have shocked the nation.
Uh, I guess the real shock was how incompetent
the process was, but Pete, Buddha judge with
his comments suggesting I guess that it was
shocking that he was doing so well at least
in the early numbers.
Then Bernie Sanders, Bernie Sanders says that
Bernie has his own internal polling saying
he got 29% of the vote Buddha judge 24% Warren
21 with Joe Biden in a distant fourth at 12%
and we'll talk about the Biden thing in a
second.
This is all now being compounded by the claim
that the unreleased Demoine register poll
from the weekend had these results which were
Bernie first Biden fourth yesterday.
I told you that over the weekend the Des Moines
register decided not to release their last
poll before voting because of a claim that
had been made that someone who was interviewed
for the poll said when they asked me the question
about who I support and they read me the list
of candidates, they didn't read every candidate
and that of course is a really big deal when
you were doing polling.
So the Des Moines register on that basis said
they were canceling the release of the poll
that however, uh, the, the claim now is from
five 38 that it was in that unreleased pole,
Bernie 22 war in 18 boot edge edge 16 and
Biden 13 and that is very similar to what
Bernie's internal polling is showing.
If these results or some version of them are
accurate, this is a potential game changer
for Joe Biden.
Joe Biden in a sense had the most to lose
last night because as the longtime presumptive
front runner, even though he was pulling a
close second in Iowa going in yesterday, if
Biden ends up with half of the support that
polling showed, this is extraordinarily damaging
to Joe Biden.
And if that's the case, I wouldn't be surprised
to see the DNC establishment rapidly shift
likely to Pete boot edge edge.
You would think maybe they would go to Klobuchar
but Klobuchar that even worse than Joe Biden
yesterday based just on those early results
that we had.
We'll see what the final numbers show and
that could be a disaster for Joe Biden.
But then if you zoom out a little bit, and
this is really the tragedy, this is a fiasco
that plays directly into Donald Trump's hands
who immediately started making fun of the
whole process on Twitter.
It's a great effect.
And why wouldn't he?
The process became a complete and total farce.
Trump tweeting about how a coin toss is used
to decide who gets a laugh delegate within
a particular precinct.
And that's true.
That's part of the process.
Check out this video of
a coin toss happening yesterday
while you're watching and then flip it over.
Pets.
In
the end, these single delegates decided by
a coin toss make very little difference, but
it looks really silly when people are voting
and then you flip a coin.
It's crazy.
Trump.
Then tweeting quote, the Democrat caucus is
an unmitigated disaster.
Nothing works just like they ran the country.
Remember the $5 billion Obamacare website
that should have cost 2% of that.
The only person that can claim a very big
victory in Iowa last night is Trump and you
know what guys?
He's right.
Unfortunately, this gives a ton of visibility
for their keep government out of stuff ideology.
Now in reality, the issue here is the DNC,
not the government, but it doesn't matter.
And case in point, Trump re-tweeting a guy,
I know a guy Benson who posted, no but seriously
read.
Let us run your health care.
They said now it's a complete wrong reaction
to last night's fiasco.
The DNC wouldn't be running healthcare, but
still this stuff works.
The fiasco plays directly into everything
that they are arguing and have been doing
for years at this point in time and the way
in which this might again mess up the credibility
of the entire primary process is raining.
Once again, and I'll explain what I mean by
that.
Imagine that Joe Biden is expecting to come
in first or second based on the polling and
he ends up fourth or fifth as he might end
up based on the early results we have after
this fiasco with a delay for quality control
followed by, we just don't have any results.
We'll get them to you.
Hopefully sometime tomorrow.
If you're Joe Biden, you were pulling for
a second and you want and you end up coming
in fourth, fifth you immediately say, I don't
believe these results.
I don't believe these results can be trusted
and you either say foul play or just errors
or whatever the case may be and then you immediately
have a disastrous situation where the presumptive
front runner, at least for a long time, right,
is publicly saying, I don't trust our own
results in this primary caucus.
It's a disaster.
It's an unmet, to quote Trump, it is an unmitigated
disaster for Democrats.
It will further divide Democrats.
It will help Donald Trump even more.
It's truly sickening and it allows Trump and
the right.
It allows anyone who wants to make the case
that Democrats are incapable of governing
to make it on the basis that they can't even
get a caucus right now.
I know that in the end there will probably
be explanations that go back to, you know,
it was whoever the technology was outsourced
to that dropped the ball and they're offering
a refund for what they charge to make this
app.
It doesn't matter.
What matters is story and narrative and that
is the story right now.
I'm curious whether tonight Donald Trump will
take advantage of this fiasco in the state
of the union speech, which we will carry live
on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook starting at
eight 30 the speeches at 9:00 PM join me early
at 8:30 PM Eastern time.
I hope you'll join.
I have published tonight's state of the union
bingo card to my Twitter page at Dee Pacman.
You can download it and play along.
We'll see who, uh, who ends up with bingo
tonight